- Le Qatar tel qu'il veut
qu'on le voie, l'amour du ballon
rond l'emporte sur la politique
pour lesinininines de milliers
d'amateurs venus rêver de
remporter cette Coupe du monde.
(chant)
Au coeur de Doha, la fête
rerererend jamais de pause.
(slogan)
Les partisans de toutes les
(chant)
Au coeur de Doha, la fête
ne prend jamais de pause.
(slogan)
Les partisans de toutes les
nationalités fraternisent.
Beaucoup sont étonnés
de leur expérience.
- En tous cas, en Europe,
on entendait beaucoup de choses
négatives sur le Qatar, sur
l'organisation, sur les esprits
assez renfermés ici, alors que,
dès qu'on est arrivés,
c'était pas du tout le cas.
Les Qataris étaient très
accueillants. L'hospitalité
était vraiment incroyable.
- Des partisans non intimidés
par l'interdiction de vente
d'alcool dans les stades;
ils trouvent d'autres endroits
où ils peuvent boire.
- Comme partout dans le monde,
il y a des restos, des bars
qui sont accessibles.
Même dans les "fan zones
il y a accès à l'alcool là-bas.
- De nombreuses partisanes
se disent aussi agréablement
surprises, en autantleleleles
respectent les nombreuses
règles, dont celles sur le code
vestimentaire.
- On s'est posé upupupup de
questions : comment on allait
s'habiller? Même si on est de
confession musulmane, hein,
on s'est d q q q quand même :
est-ce-que ici, on pouvait être
libres, venir seules? Parce que
je suis venue seule, elle aussi.
Donce poe poe poe posait beaucop
de questions, mais finalement,
ça se passe très, très bien.
- Être ici comme visiteur
rarararavailler ici, ça serait
deux différentes choses. Alors,
selon moi, si j'avais le choix,
je ne choisirais pas Qatar,commr
ici, parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de choses, genre voter et puis
l'accès à l'éducation.
- Les étrangers résidant
au Qatar profitent de l'esprit
festif temporaire en raison
du Mondial.
Ces partisans ont déboursé
des milliers de dollars pour
pouvoir vivre l'expérience de la
Coupe du monde. Dans leur cas,
l'opération séduction du Qatar